♪ ♪
>> Tucker: REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN MATT GAETZ OF
FLORIDA HAS INTRODUCED A BILL
THE FISA COURTS, THE COURTS THAT
ALLOW THE GOVERNMENT TO SPY ON
YOU BY MAKING JUDGES SUBJECT A
PRESIDENTIAL APPOINTMENT AT
SENATE CONFIRMATION, BRINGING
DEMOCRACY AND TRANSPARENCY TO
THE PROCESS.
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN ADAM
SCHIFF OF CALIFORNIA MAY FIND
THAT BILL FAMILIAR.
HE INTRODUCED THE EXACT SAME
BILL WORD FOR WORD FIVE YEARS
AGO.
APPARENTLY THIS TIME HE IS NOT
EAGER TO BACK HIS OWN LAW.
WHY IS THAT?
DID HIS PRINCIPLES CHANGE OR DID
HIS SHORT-TERM POLITICAL
CALCULATIONS?
WE INVITED CONGRESSMAN MATT
GAETZ TO JOIN US AS WELL AS
FORMER HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN,
TO ADVISOR, RICHARD GOODSTEIN.
TO YOU, CONGRESSMAN, THIS IS A
WORD FOR WORD THE SAME BILL.
TELL ME IF I'M WRONG.
THE PERSON WHO WROTE THE BILL IS
REFUSING TO SUPPORT IT OR SEEMS
LIKE YOU WANT.
WHY IS THAT?
>> IT SEEMS ODD THAT WHEN
BARACK OBAMA WAS PRESIDENT,
DEMOCRATS WANTED TO GIVE THAT
PRESIDENT MORE POWER TO WORK
WITH ASSENTED TO GET MEMBERS OF
THE FISA FOR THAT AREN'T PART OF
THE D.C. SWAMP, BUT THAT COME
FROM ALL OVER AMERICA, AND
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REPRESENT THE VALUES THAT
AMERICANS HOLD DEAR REGARDING
THEIR LIBERTIES.
I DID NOT CHANGE ONE COMMA AND
ADAM SCHIFF'S BILL, BECAUSE I
THINK EVERYONE TO DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS WILL BE IN POWER INT
REPUBLICANS WILL BE IN POWER INE
FUTURE.
I THINK WE OUGHT TO WORK
TOGETHER RATHER THAN WORK
SEPARATELY.
>> Tucker: THAT HE SEND YOU A
THANKFUL TEXT?
>> I ASKED FOR HIM TO COSPONSOR
IT AND I HAVE NOT HEARD BACK.
>> Tucker: HOW STRANGE IS
THAT.
RICHARD, WOULD YOU MIND CALLING
HIM?
I WANT TO BE CLEAR: GOOD FOR
ADAM SCHIFF, WHOM I RARELY
COMPLEMENT, FOR INTRODUCING THIS
BILL IN THE FIRST PLACE FIVE
YEARS AGO.
IT SEEMS LIKE A COMMON SENSE
REFORM.
WHY WOULDN'T HE SUPPORTED NOW?
INTRODUCED A BILL?
IN LIGHT OF THE EDWARD SNOWDEN
LEAKS THAT WERE THANKS TO
WIKILEAKS, WHO WERE VILIFIED BY
REPUBLICANS BACK THEN AND
DONALD TRUMP SAID, I LOVE
WIKILEAKS ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
MY POINT IS THAT THINGS GET
TWISTED IN ODD WAYS.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
HE WASN'T JUST VILIFIED BY
REPUBLICANS, ALSO BY DEMOCRATS.
TO BE FAIR, I DON'T KNOW WHY
REPUBLICANS DIDN'T SUPPORTED
THEM.
THEY SHOULD SUPPORTED AND SO
SHOULD EVERYONE.
HONESTLY, HOW COULD ADAM SCHIFF,
WHO POSES AS A MAN OF PRINCIPLE,
THEY ALSO SUPPORT HIS OWN BILL?
THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE, DOES
IT?
>> I THINK THE RULES OF THE
SENATE HAVE CHANGED ABOUT
CONFIRMING JUDGES.
YOU'D HAVE TO ASK HIM.
I AM NOT HERE --
>> Tucker: YOU'D HAVE TO BE.
>> BACK THEN, HE HAD RON WYDEN
AND OTHER LIBERAL DEMOCRATS WHO
WERE SUPPORTING THE PRINCIPAL,
THE INTERESTS OF PROTECTING
INDIVIDUAL FREEDOMS.
I THINK THERE WAS SOMETHING
BEHIND IT.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
ALL OF THIS GETS TO THE CORE
QUESTION, THESE DUELING MEMOS,
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRAT, NUNES
AND SCHIFF, GET TO THE QUESTION
OF THE FISA WARRANT.
WHAT DID THE DOJ SAY IN ORDER TO
SPY ON CARTER PAGE?
WHY CAN'T WE SEE THAT?
WHY CAN'T WE DECIDE FOR
OURSELVES?
>> WE SHOULD, TUCKER.
I'M GLAD THAT THE WHITE HOUSE
HAS JOINED THE CALL TO SEE MORE
OF WHAT WAS A MESS FISA
APPLICATION AND I THINK THAT WE
WILL BE ABLE TO SEE THINGS THAT
ADAM SCHIFF WROTE THAT ARE
VERIFIABLY UNTRUE.
I THINK THAT WILL BOLSTER THE
CLAIMS THAT WE ARE MAKING ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE THAT THERE NEEDS
TO BE REFORM AND THERE NEEDS TO
BE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR PEOPLE AT
THE FBI WHO WITHHELD THE
POLITICAL ORIGINS OF THIS
DOSSIER FROM THE COURT.
THAT IS THE REAL PROBLEM HERE.
THERE IS NO DISPUTE THAT CASH AT
THE DNC WAS CONVERTIBLE INTO A
GOVERNMENT-SPONSORED WARRANT TO
SPY ON AMERICAN CITIZENS.
WHETHER YOU ARE A REPUBLICAN OR
DEMOCRAT, THAT SHOULD CONCERN
YOU BECAUSE IT COULD HAPPEN TO
ANY OF US.
THAT IS WHY WE NEED REFORM AND
FRANKLY, IT BE NICE IF WE DIDN'T
ALL GO TO OUR SEPARATE CORNERS
POLITICALLY, IF WE FOUND
IDEAS THAT REPUBLICANS OR
DEMOCRATS HAD OFFERED THAT WOULD
PROVIDE THE TRANSPARENCY AND
OVERSIGHT TO GIVE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE CONFIDENCE.
TO SPEED WHEN I AGREE.
WHO KNOWS, BUT A REALLY,
SINCERELY HOPE, THAT IF THE
ROLES WERE REVERSED, AND THE RNC
HAD PAID FOR A DOCUMENT, THAT
SOME REPUBLICAN ADMINISTRATION
HAD USED TO SPY ON A RIVAL
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN, THAT WOULD
BE PRINCIPLED ENOUGH TO SAY THAT
IS AN ABUSE OF POWER BECAUSE IT
IS.
I'M SURE YOU AGREE IS A CIVIL
LIBERTARIAN, YOU JUST SAID YOU
WERE.
WE SHOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT THAT.
BYE SHOULDN'T WE SEE THE FISA
APPLICATION?
>> I AM A CIVIL LIBERTARIAN.
I MORE SO AN AMERICAN CITIZEN
WHO CARES FOR THE INTEGRITY OF
THE UNITED STATES AND THE FBI
WAS CONCERNED WITH -- FOR GOOD
REASON -- IS THAT CARTER PAGE
WAS A FOREIGN AGENT.
MAYBE THEY DID IT NO TRUMP
PEOPLE KNEW.
I WILL SAY THIS, THE RUSSIANS
APPROACHED ONE CAMPAIGN, AND ONE
CAMPAIGN ONLY.
>> Tucker: I KNOW, HE'S IN THE
POCKET OF PUTIN.
IT'S REALLY SIMPLE.
WHY CAN'T WE SEE THE FISA
APPLICATION?
THIS IS OUR GOVERNMENT.
THEY SPIED AN AMERICAN CITIZEN.
WHY CAN'T WE KNOW?
>> YOU HAVE TO ASK THE FISA --
>> Tucker: WHY WOULD I SUPPORT
THAT?
WHY DON'T DEMOCRATS SAY LET'S
END THIS NONSENSE.
>> FISA A SECRET BY DESIGN.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS, WHAT
SCHIFF SAID AND IS UNREBUTTED IS
THAT THE DOSSIER HAD RELATIVELY
LITTLE ROLE IN GETTING OUT
WARRANT.
>> Tucker: LET'S FIND OUT.
>> THERE WAS A REFERENCE --
>> Tucker: HOW DO WE KNOW?
IS THERE ANY SUPPORT IN
CONGRESS, IF THE RUSSIANS WANT
TO CONTROL THE POLITICAL
PROCESS, THEY ARE DOING IT NOW,
PARALYZING THIS DEBATE, WHICH WE
COULD END INSTANTLY BY MAKING IT
PUBLIC.
IS THERE SUPPORT?
>> AS LONG AS WE ARE ABLE TO
REDACT SOURCES AND METHODS COME
WHERE I THINK WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO FIND AGREEMENT, I DON'T THINK
THE DEMOCRATS WILL WANT TO DO
THAT BECAUSE THE DOSSIER
WAS THE LEAD PIECE OF EVIDENCE,
IT IS WHAT EVERY LAWYER YOU
KNOW --
>> Tucker: WHY NOT AND THE
POISON?
>> I AGREE WITH THE CONGRESSMAN
THAT THEY SHOULD BE PUT OUT.
THERE IS NO DISPUTING THAT THE
WHOLE INVESTIGATION PRECEDED THE
DOSSIER BEEN CONCLUDED.
PAPADOPOULOS WAS THE TIP OF THAT
SPEAR.
>> Tucker: WE DON'T KNOW THAT.
LET'S FIND OUT AND THEN WE COULD
DO A SHOW ON IT.
NO RUSH UNTIL THE CONGRESS